“El estado peruano enfrenta difíciles retos
a corto y mediano plazo; necesita una nueva
forma de hacer minería en su territorio”
Pedro Castillo.
Queridos amigos, amigas, con esta frase el
nuevo y controvertido presidente del Perú
quiso dejar claras sus intenciones durante
su discurso de investidura.
“una nueva forma de hacer minería”.
Y no solo eso, Pedro Castillo ha prometido
toda una revolución política y también
económica para el país.
De esta forma, por ejemplo, durante este mismo
discurso inaugural también dejó claro que
a partir de ahora el estado peruano exigirá
a todos los proyectos mineros e industriales
más impuestos y también cumplir con un nuevo
criterio: la rentabilidad social.
(“Si un proyecto no tiene rentabilidad
social, simplemente no va”,)
Es decir, que para que un proyecto sea aprobado
ya no sólo tendrá que ser rentable y pagar
los impuestos convenidos al estado peruano,
sino que ahora también tendrá que cumplir
con otras cuestiones cómo, no sé, dinamizar
la economía del entorno, apoyar la cultura
local o preservar el medio ambiente.
[Lo que por otra parte, pues, ya se supone
que hacen con su actividad, con los impuestos
que pagan y con las regulaciones y normas
que les exige el estado. Bueno, todo esto
de la rentabilidad social es algo que el nuevo
gobierno tendrá que detallar.]
(“Cuando [Pedro Castillo] habla de rentabilidad
social, es fácil advertir que no conoce el
aporte tributario de la minería ni el impulso
directo e indirecto de la mano de obra que
generan los proyectos mineros, ni su nivel
de innovación y transferencia tecnológica”,
Carlos Gálvez, ex presidente de la Sociedad
Nacional de Minería, Petróleo y Energía.)
La cuestión es que Pedro Castillo, oriundo
de Cajamarca, una de las regiones mineras
más importantes del Perú, ha puesto a esta
industria en su punto de mira.
("Pedro Castillo dice que no permitirá que
las empresas mineras "saqueen" a Perú". Milenio)
("Pedro Castillo: Nacionalizaremos mineras
si el pueblo lo requiere: Exitosa")
Y, ojo, porque estamos hablando del sector
más importante de la economía peruana. Perú
es una potencia minera a nivel mundial y sólo
los proyectos actualmente en marcha suman
decenas y decenas de miles de millones de
dólares.
Y eso, eso ha hecho que en VisualPolitik nos
hagamos unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Qué papel tiene realmente la minería en
el Perú? ¿Por qué Pedro Castillo ha puesto
a las minas en la diana? ¿Cómo es posible
que esta industria genere tanto rechazo social?
¿Cómo puede este sector contribuir al futuro
del Perú? Y quizás la pregunta más importante
de todas: ¿Qué es exactamente lo que está
en juego?
Atentos.
[Por cierto si quieres estar al tanto de todo
lo que ocurre en América Latina no te pierdas
Latampolitik, nuestra newsletter dedicada
específicamente a la actualidad de esta región.
Os dejamos todos los detalles en la descripción.]
(MINERÍA EN EL PERÚ: EN BUSCA Y CAPTURA)
Queridos amigos,amigas, el Perú es una de
las mayores potencias mineras de todo el planeta.
Por ejemplo, según el Servicio Geológico
de Estados Unidos, en 2019 el país fue el
segundo mayor productor de cobre, plata y
zinc de todo el mundo. También fue uno de
los mayores productores de oro, plomo y estaño
entre otros muchos recursos.
Porque si algo está claro es que el país
tiene prácticamente de todo.
(“Muchos otros países mineros tienen principalmente
un solo mineral y esto les agrega un riesgo
adicional cuando los precios fluctúan. Perú
tiene la ventaja de poder suavizar algunas
de las fluctuaciones de precios, a partir
de esta canasta diversificada de metales”.
Diego Macera, gerente general del Instituto
Peruano de Economía)
Todo esto explica que la minería suponga
en torno al 10% del PIB del país.
Y no solo eso. También genera, como veremos,
entre el 15 y el 20% de todos los ingresos
públicos y es responsable de casi el 60%
de las exportaciones nacionales.
Para que os hagáis una idea, entre los años
2010 y 2019 el país ingresó anualmente una
media de 25.000 millones de dólares en exportaciones
mineras. Lo que supone tal y como os podéis
imaginar una fuente de divisas vital para
la economía peruana.
Y ahí, ahí no acaba todo.
(El sector minero también emplea directamente
a unos 200 mil trabajadores formales y se
calcula que genera indirectamente más de
1,3 millones de puestos de trabajo adicionales.
Entre otras cosas porque los trabajos del
sector minero son más productivos y se caracterizan
por pagar salarios mucho más altos, algo
más del doble, que los habituales en el resto
de la economía peruana.)
Además, luego tendríamos que tener en cuenta
a cerca de medio millón de personas más
que se calcula trabajan en lo que se conoce
como la minería informal, es decir la que
se realiza de forma ilegal o al margen de
los permisos y las regulaciones del estado.
Luego hablaremos de ello.
Resumiendo, que para la economía peruana
la minería es casi tan importante como lo
son los huevos para hacer una tortilla.
Sin embargo, echad el freno, porque pese a
todo ello, tal y cómo hemos visto, el nuevo
gobierno ha puesto a esta industria en la
diana.
Así que la pregunta que todos podríamos
hacernos es, ¿Por qué demonios un gobierno
se lanza a la yugular de una industria tan
importante para el país?
Pues no penséis por un instante que lo hace
por casualidad o falta de miras. Al menos
de miras políticas.
Lo cierto, amigos, es que la minería es una
industria terriblemente impopular en el Perú.
¿Por qué? Pues por varios motivos. En primer
lugar porque tiene un impacto muy alto sobre
el terreno.
(La actividad minera ocupa enormes cantidades
de suelo. Por ejemplo, una única explotación
como es el caso de Yanacocha, la mina de oro
más grande de Sudamérica ocupa una extensión
de 10km de largo por 5 de ancho. 50 km2.
Y, desde luego, no solo se trata del terreno.
También necesita enormes cantidades de agua
en zonas donde en no pocos casos los habitantes
tienen serios problemas de suministro.
Luego habitualmente el trasiego de camiones
y maquinaria tambien afecta a la vida, a las
cosechas y a los pastos de las zonas rurales
por la gran cantidad de polvo que se levanta
y, además, si no se hacen bien las cosas
el riesgo de contaminación es muy alto, con
serias implicaciones, incluso, para la salud
de las personas.)
Aún con todo el mayor problema es la sensación
que tienen las comunidades rurales de estas
siendo “robadas”. Es decir, que el enorme
negocio que las compañías mineras hacen
con las explotaciones en el Perú no termina
traduciéndose en una mejora clara de sus
condiciones de vida. Y eso, eso cuándo no
experimentan directamente en un perjuicio.
Ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso de Cajamarca,
el hogar natal de Pedro Castillo y la región
más pobre del Perú a pesar de tener una
potente industria minera y muchísimos recursos
naturales por explotar.
Pese a ello, las carreteras y las infraestructuras
son deplorables, casi la mitad de la población
se encuentra en una situación de pobreza
severa
( “Ni siquiera pagan impuestos de una manera
justa; desde aquí sacan el oro que se envía
a todas partes del mundo y las comunidades
de Cajamarca seguimos viviendo en la miseria”.
Juan Chillón, activista y político de izquierdas
peruano)
El recelo hacia la minería es tan grande
que a pesar de ser una región tan pobre,
las autoridades han frenado en los últimos
años proyectos mineros multimillonarios.
Ese fue el caso, por ejemplo, del Proyecto
Conga, una enorme explotación de oro que
conllevaba una inversión inicial de casi
5.000 millones de dólares.
Hablamos de un sentimiento que se ha ido extendiendo
a lo largo y ancho de todo el país, especialmente
en las regiones más mineras.
Y todo esto es lo que explica tantos y tantos
conflictos sociales. Por ejemplo, según la
Defensoría del Pueblo, tan sólo durante
el primer trimestre del 2021 se registraron
80 conflictos activos relacionados con la
minería.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué hay de verdad en todo esto?
¿Es cierto que las mineras son tan irresponsables?
¿Es verdad que no pagan apenas impuestos?
Pues, amigos, como en toda buena historia
vamos a poder encontrar claroscuros.
Respecto al impacto ambiental y la explotación
laboral, hay que decir que la mayoría de
problemas están asociados a la minería ilegal
o la mala praxis de los funcionarios que tienen
el deber de controlar el cumplimiento de la
regulación establecida o perseguir las explotaciones
ilegales.
Y, ojo, porque no hablamos de cuestiones menores.
Fijaos.
(Según estimaciones de la consultora Macroconsult,
casi el 30% de toda la producción de oro
se llevó a cabo en minas ilegales. Minas,
que, por supuesto, no cumplen con las exigencias
ambientales, ni de seguridad laboral, ni de
protección de la salud pública, ni absolutamente
nada de nada.
La minería ilegal ha sido la responsable
de deforestar enormes cantidades de bosques,
envenenar suelos y poner en riesgo la salud
de miles y miles de personas. Esto es así
porque en la minería se utilizan reactivos
muy tóxicos que de no gestionarse correctamente
pueden ocasionar muchísimos problemas.)
Y justo ahora llegamos a la cuestión clave:
¿Tienen razón Pedro Castillo y tantos otros
activistas y políticos peruanos que denuncian
que las multinacionales mineras apenas pagan
impuestos?
¿Es cierto que están saqueando las riquezas
del Perú?
¿Por qué demonios cuesta tanto ver avances
económicos en los entornos mineros?
Atentos.
(EL DINERO QUE NO LLEGA)
¿Es acaso cierto que las grandes mineras
apenas pagan impuestos en el Perú?
Pues… para responder a esta pregunta lo
primero que tenemos que tener en cuenta es
que en Perú la minería se enfrenta a 3 impuestos
principales:
Por un lado, como cualquier otra empresa,
al Impuesto a la Renta, esto es, el impuesto
sobre los beneficios. Pero luego también
tiene que hacer frente a las regalías mineras,
al impuesto especial a la minería y al gravamen
especial a la minería.
El resultado de todo ello, es que según cálculos
del Instituto Peruano de Economía, las empresas
mineras que operan en Perú se enfrentan a
una carga fiscal de al menos el 47,07% sobre
sus beneficios.
Lo que está por encima del promedio de los
principales países mineros. Es decir, en
Perú las empresas mineras pagan más de lo
que es habitual en países como Canadá, Australia,
Chile o Estados Unidos entre otros muchos.
Tan solo entre 2009-2019, las empresas mineras
en Perú pagaron en impuestos 85.000 millones
de soles. Unos 25.000 millones de dólares
al cambio de aquel momento.
Y, ojo, porque a esta carga fiscal tenemos
que añadir el dinero que las mineras abonan
en salarios, en cotizaciones sociales y por
contratos con empresas locales.
Si metemos todo en la ecuación queda claro
meridiano que el Perú gana mucho, muchísimo
más con las explotaciones mineras que cualquier
empresas que explotan yacimientos en el país.
[Vamos, que saqueo, saqueo, lo que se dice
saqueo pues como que no]
Pero entonces, ¿por qué diantres las comunidades
parecen no avanzar? ¿Por qué en muchos casos
la población local tiene el sentimiento de
que las multinacionales se llevan los recursos
y ellos se quedan sin nada?
Pues amigos, amigas, justo aquí es cuándo
llegamos a lo que se conoce como el Canon
minero.
(Los entes subnacionales, las regiones, los
municipios y los distritos donde existe actividad
minera reciben cada año el 50% de los ingresos
recaudados por el estado, para gastarlo en
principio en inversión pública.
Y junto al canon minero encontramos también
el canon gasífero, el petrolero y las regalías
mineras. Es decir, que los entes subnacionales
de las zonas donde se explotan los recursos
naturales reciben un montón de ingresos cada
año.)
Hablamos de más de 2.000 millones de dólares
anuales para regiones que por lo general son
muy pobres. A pesar de ello, el descontento
social parece más que evidente.
("Localidades que más canon minero recibieron
votaron por Perú Libre". La República)
Pues bien, ¿Sabéis cuál es el problema?
Que por el bajo nivel de la clase política
peruana - del que ya os hablamos en un reciente
vídeo que os dejo en la descripción - lo
gastan mal, y cuando consiguen gastarlo.
Porque según datos del MEF entre 2009 y 2019
apenas lograron ejecutar poco más del 60%
del presupuesto disponible. Esto supone que
las principales regiones mineras se dejan
en el cajón más de 1.800 millones de soles
anuales pagados por la industria minera.
Es decir, que estos entes subnacionales han
acumulado miles y miles de millones de soles
en las cuentas del banco nacional, al tiempo
que sus regiones carecen de todo tipo de infraestructuras
básicas. Y eso no es culpa de las minas sino
de la política.
(“Acá la plata sobra. Las autoridades subnacionales
no tienen que pedir más recursos. Lo que
se tiene que trabajar es en cómo gestionar
mejor esos recursos. El discurso de que las
empresas aportan muy poco, que algunos afirman,
desconoce el exceso de recursos que tienen
estas autoridades”. Luis Miguel Castilla,
Director de Videnza Consultores)
En 2020, por la crisis del coronavirus el
canon fue mucho más reducido, apenas 4.504
millones de soles. Pues bien, a pesar de ello
los gobiernos y municipios subnacionales apenas
ejecutaron poco más del 50%.
Y luego a lo que logran gastar hay que restar
la corrupción.
Antes veíamos por ejemplo el caso de Cajamarca,
la región más pobre del Perú y el lugar
natal de Pedro Castillo.
(Cajamarca es una región de 1,3 millones
de habitantes donde casi el 50% de la población
vive en condiciones de pobreza severa, donde
el 20% de las viviendas no tienen electricidad,
el 26% no tienen servicio de agua corriente
y el 62% no están conectadas a redes de saneamiento.
Pues bien, sólo entre 2009 y 2018 esta región
recibió del canon minero y las regalías
casi 1.200 millones de dólares para realizar
inversión pública. De toda esta cantidad
casi la mitad, el 47% no se ejecutó, no se
gastó.)
Y a pesar de ello, casi el 30% del presupuesto
público de los entes subnacionales de esta
región se financiaron con cargo al Canon
Minero y las regalías.
Amigos, aquí y en la minería ilegal, que
evidentemente no paga nada, es dónde está
el gran problema y el porque muchos peruanos
tienen la impresión de que las mineras pagan
mucho menos de lo que realmente pagan.
Ahora bien, llegamos a la última gran pregunta
¿Qué consecuencias puede tener Castillo
para el futuro de la minería peruana?
Atentos.
(¿AUSTRALIA O VENEZUELA? LA ALTERNATIVA LATINOAMERICANA)
Amigos, el desarrollo de las energías verdes
está disparando la demanda de productos minerales
de todo tipo, lo que está incrementando sus
precios. Esto supone una oportunidad para
países como Perú.
(En estos momentos el país andino, pacífico
y amazónico tiene una cartera de proyectos
mineros con inversiones estimadas de casi
60.000 millones de dólares. Proyectos que
según estimados del Instituto Peruano de
Economía podrían traducirse en ingresos
fiscales de miles y miles de millones de dólares
durante los próximos años.)
El problema es que muchos de estos proyectos
están frenados y para colmo la llegada de
Castillo puede hacer que se frenen aún más.
Esto es lo que se juega en Perú.
Amigos, las cosas en el pasado no se han hecho
en muchos casos bien. La dejadez de muchas
compañías, la corrupción y la incompetencia
de los gobiernos locales han ralentizado el
desarrollo del país. Pero eso son cosas que
se pueden solventar.
Perú necesita inversión y la industria mineral,
tal y como ocurre en Australia, puede ser
un gran motor de prosperidad.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Qué impacto crees que puede tener la llegada
de Castillo para la industria más importante
del Perú? ¿Cumplirá sus amenazas o finalmente
será pragmático?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.